mais bon vous avez vu euh les nombre de
personnes que nous avons auditionné
juste avant vous madame la présidente
directrice général mesdames merci
d'avoir répondu à à notre invitation
pour nous apporter voilà votre votre
constat mais ça je crois que on le
connaît plus ou moins d'ors et déjà et
surtout qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
proposer que nous puissions faire à vos
côtés pour faire prendre conscience à
cette exécutif non seulement de la
gravité de la crise mais surtout qu'
change peut-être de logiciel et qu'on
arrête une fois pour toutes ce qu'on
entend de façon récurrente depuis 2017
et encore plus depuis
2022 du style ben voilà le logement est
une rente le marché va se réguler tout
seul et et et naturellement ou le
logement coûte trop cher et cette
politique du logement regardez il y a
toujours autant de personnes qui sont
mal logées et pourtant on dépense
toujours plus d'argent dans le logement
donc c'est aussi à travers cette mission
d'information que nous conduisons depuis
la mi-décembre sur la crise du logement
puisque le président du Sénat a souhaité
que la commission des affaires
économiques s'empare de ce sujet mais
pour parler véritablement de cette crise
du logement et comme nous avons
l'habitude de le faire au Sénat nous
travaillons sur ces sujetslà mais sur
bien d'autres de façon
transpartisane et donc nous sommes
toutes les trois rapporteur de cette
mission d'information nous souhaitons
rendre notre rapport dans le courant du
mois de mars à partir de ce rapport soit
nous avons deux possibilités soit
rédiger une proposition de loi avec tout
ou partie des propositions ou des
mesures que nous aurons pu rassembler
dans le cadre de ce rapport soit nous
pensions au moment où nous avons lancé
cette mission d'information puisque nous
avions encore à l'époque un ministre
délégué au logement et puisque ce
ministre- làà ne cessait de nous parler
de la grande loi sur le logement qui
était prévue pour arriver dans le
courant du mois d'avril nous étions dit
aussi que ça pourrait être un bon
véhicule pour y intégrer tout ou partie
de ces mesures que nous aurions pu que
nous pourrions mettre dans ce rapport à
travers des propositions d'amendement
bon aujourd'hui les cartes sont quelque
peu rebatttues d'abord parce que pour
l'heure on a toujours pas de ministre
délégué au logement bon j'espère que ça
ne tardera plus trop et puis surtout je
pense que sans avoir d'information
précise le calendrier tel qu'il avait
annoncé me paraît un petit peu compliqué
pour pour que au mois d'avril nous ayons
cette grande loi sur le logement mais
peut-être me trompe peut-être que je me
trompe mais voilà donc aujourd'hui nous
travaillons en essayant
d'auditionner le spectre le plus large
possible qui intervient sur le marché du
logement mais au sens large du terme
puisque bien sûr d'abord avant tout les
acteurs du logement dont vous
représentez une partie importante mais
on a aussi déjà auditionné des
chercheurs des experts euh et puis aussi
euh euh par exemple la direction
générale du Trésor enfin donc on va
continuer à euh auditionner on a
auditionné l'OCDE enfin pour essayer
d'avoir un petit peu voilà un spectre
très large avec aussi euh des euh des
informations sur ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays euh que que que que le
nôtre donc en tout cas on est très très
heureuse de vous accueillir Madame
Véronique Bedag président directrice
générale de Next City le plus gros euh
promoteur immobilier euh parce que Ben
vous être une personne qui fait
référence en la matière parce que vous
avez été avec christophe Robert
coanimatrice de ce fameux Conseil
national de la refondation qui a suscité
certainement beaucoup d'espoir beaucoup
d'attentes mais qui malheureusement a
été voilà abouti à énormément de
frustration puisque je crois pouvoir
dire que toutes les les les personnes
qui avaient travaillé pendant de longs
mois dans ces groupes de travail à vos
côtés et qui ont vraiment voilà donner
le meilleur de même bah tout a été
quasiment balayé d'un revers de la main
et donc c'est particulièrement
préoccupant et puis parce qu'on vous
voit encore vous exprimer fort
heureusement je lisais votre interview
dans la tribune d'hier et ce matin vous
étiez je crois à France Info aussi où
vous avez voilà des des des des des des
des propos qui qui percutent et en tout
cas qui on le mérite de pouvoir faire
bouger si j'ose dire le cocotier ou
essayer de de renverser la table pour
qu'on ait enfin cette prise de
conscience donc il y a déjà quasiment un
jour un an jour pour jour vous étiez
auditionné par la commission des
affaires économiques en réunion plinière
on parlait déjà de crise du logement
sans peut-être voir combien elle allait
rapidement encore plus s'aggraver et
vous aviez déjà employé des mots forts
pour en appeler à l'état stratège par
rapport à une crise que les seuls
mesures conjoncturelles forcément
limitées ne peuvent pas endiguer
aujourd'hui quel est votre
regard sur la situation du logement dans
notre pays où la crise par paraisse être
approfondie déjà pour 2024 mais on peut
être aussi malheureusement pessimiste
déjà pour 2025 voire même jusqu'en 2026
année des élections municipales donc je
le disais vous êtes à la tête d'un des
principaux acteurs de l'immobilier
agissant sur presque tout le spectre
comment la crise se traduit-elle pour
votre entreprise et comment la
voyez-vous évoluer enfin nous sommes à
l'écoute de vos propositions alors bien
entendu certaines ont être débattu au
sein du CNR mais sans doute ne faut-il
pas s'y limiter je crois que on a
beaucoup entendu parler du bailleur du
statut privé du du du statut du bailleur
privé mais bon qui ne débouche sur rien
même si tout le monde le dit au effort
j'ai personnellement l'intuition que le
logement est arrivé au bout d'un cycle
économique mais aussi de pensé et qu'il
nous faut peut-être chercher des
solutions en dehors du cadre plus
traditionnel tel qu'on avait l'habitude
de le de l'imaginer suite à l'audition
la semaine dernière du chercheur
François Rochon qui a souligné combien
le logement était devenu une politique
silencieuse réduite à des questions
techniques et dont les grands choix ne
sont plus débattus je me demande s'il ne
faudrait pas lancer l'écriture alors
peut-être faut-il pas employer ce terme
mais c'est le plus facile et
compréhensible d'un livre blanc sur le
logement il il en a pas eu depuis
1975 bien entendu cela ne devrait pas
être un nouveau rapport parmi d'autres
mais comme on le fait en matière de
défense la volonté à partir d'un état
des lieux et d'une analyse des risques
de définir les objectifs et de préparer
des décisions pour les 5 ou 10 ans à
venir parce que on le dit pas
suffisamment nous on le sait la
politique du logement elle s'inscrit
dans le temps long et malheureusement on
est toujours sur du court terme à
travers des mesures conjoncturelles qui
viennent un petit peu penser quelqu PL
deci de là mais qui ne donnent pas ni de
perspective ni de visibilité ni quelque
part une stabilité des outils effectifs
étant à la clé dans une loi peut-être de
programmation compte tenu de votre
expérience de l'État j'aimerais savoir
ce que vous en pensez voilà donc je vous
laisse la parole sans plus tarder et
ensuite mes collègues que j'ai oublié de
vous présenter Amel gaaker qui est
sénatriste centriste du patcalé Vian
artigala sénatrice socialiste des Hautes
Pyrénées et moi-même cénatrice LR des
Alpes mar team ne manqueront pas de
réagir à vos propos voilà je vous laisse
la parole madame la présidente madame la
Présidente Mesdames les signatrices
monsieurs vous avez déjà dit beaucoup de
choses et et au fond en venant à cette
audition je me disais elles savent déjà
tellement de choses qu'est-ce que je
vais bien pouvoir leur
apprendre donc c'est un peu comme ça
qu'on a tenté de réfléchir on va redire
des choses un peu générales et puis j'ai
choisi aujourd'hui de parler plutôt de
l'investissement du logement comme
investissement si vous le voulez bien
qu'on alors au fond pour répondre à
votre question sur le livre blanc moi
quand quand je regarde en arrière et que
je je regarde le CNR parce que vous
l'avez dit quand même il y a eu beaucoup
de enfin moi j'ai j'ai beaucoup aimé ce
moment je dois vous le dire parce que il
y avait il y avait une vraie énergie
très
positive d'un secteur qui dans toutes
ces composantes s beaucoup mobilisé qui
pensaiit qu'il allait se passer quelque
chose puisqueon nous avait demandé de
bon moi je pense que rétrospectivement
ce qui nous a manqué quand même ce qui
n'a jamais été possible de faire c'est
un vrai diagnostic sur la situation
c'est un peu bête quand même nous sommes
nous convaincus mais c'est parce que on
est au contact au fond de nos clients
dans les agences qu'il y a besoin de
plus de logement dans ce pays qu'il y a
aussi des gens mal logés et que ces
sujets doivent être traités mais vous
savez aussi qu'il y a je pense que ça
n'est pas un secret une partie du
gouvernement qui pense qu'il y a pas de
problème de logement enfin c'est quand
même c'est donc déjà ça commence pas
bien enfin quelque part et moi à chaque
fois ce qui me frappe c'est qu'à chaque
fois que vous voyez bien à chaque fois
je mets des choses sur la table et
j'espère que quelque chose va me revenir
en disant mais non Véronique tu dis des
bêtises c'est faux tes calculs sont pas
justes ça n'arrive jamais c'est-à-dire
que je mets des choses sur la table en
espérant un retour et au fond ce ce
retour ne vient jamais donc moi je pense
que l'avantage d'un livre blanc ça
serait de poser le diagnostic
euh est-ce qu'il y a besoin au sortir du
tableau Excel où on nous explique avec
quatre données que au fond ce qu'on a eu
quand même au début du CNR vous vous en
souvenez hein que vous avez dû déjà
avoir aussi dans vos auditions bon donc
moi je pense que l'avantage d'un livre
blanc malgré tout c'est de faire ce
diagnosticque euh chacun a son avis mais
il y a jamais de moment où on tente de
trouver un consensus euh sur la demande
de logement en entendant tout le monde
la demande de logement ça dépend ça
dépend de savoir si on fait une
politique d'améliorement du territoire
ou pas quand même hein euh ça dépend de
savoir de quel type de logement on parle
ça dépend de savoir aussi si vous
souhaitez travailler si on souhaite
prendre en compte le fait qu'il y a
quand même des G gens qui vivent dans
des conditions que voilà qui ne sont pas
décentes et qu'il faut les travailler et
puis quelque fois quand les gens
travaillent dans des façons pas décente
il suffit pas de faire des travaux il
faut restructurer vraiment donc je je
pense que ce sujet diagnosticque n'a pas
été et et on entend tout et l'inverse de
tout et le contraire dans la première
proposition moi j'entends qu'on a besoin
de 200000 logements par an dans ce pays
d'ailleurs on y arrive on y arrive donc
ça va le faire très bien d'autres disent
que si on regarde tout c'est plutôt
450000 enfin je pense que quand même la
question de savoir si on a besoin de
logement supplémenta neu pour rénover
dans ce pays est une
question deuxème question vous l'avez
vous avez raison quels objectifs euh moi
je commence à être une vieille dame et
donc j'ai probablement des convictions
un peu vieilles mais je trouve que
politique d'aménagement du territoire ça
a du sens ça parle au territoire ça peut
éventuellement rééquilibrer le
territoire on a quand même un territoire
qui qui commence à se pencher comme ça
c'estàd qu'il y a il y a des habitants
qui descendent pardonnez-moi madame la
sénatrice du Nord et de l'Est pour aller
sur les côtes et dans le sud oui mais
pourquoi enfin est-ce que est-ce que
enfin voilà est-ce que ça ça se
travaille donc moi je pense que quand
même tous ces sujets doivent être mis
mis sur la table et puis après une fois
qu'on est d'accord sur le diagnostique
et les objectifs je pense que on peut
faire Fance aux administrations pour
trouver des bonnes solutions on va dire
mais forcément les administrations ne
cherchent pas de solution si elles
pensent qu'il y a pas de sujet et que
voilà on sait pas où est le chemin parce
qu'il y a pas de sujet donc je voilà
c'est un petit peu ça que c'est un peu
ma réaction à l'idée de livre blanc
euh et je pense que pour le coup le
Parlement dans son ensemble a dans le
moment un vrai rôle à
jouer c'est la courroie de transmission
des territoires enfin c'est je pense que
c'est le moment de le faire au fond hein
c'est puis faut vous rencontrer quand
même des habitants t t tous les jours
vous avez des permanences voilà je pense
que parce que moi ce que je dis n'est
pas entendu donc je pense que malgré
tout le parole d'élu est plus forte
enfin faut l'espérer alors donc si on
revient sur le logement euh et sur ce
que j'entends en fait vous savez bien
qu'il y a deux sujets le sujet le plus
dur étant la crise conjoncturelle et à
cette k conjoncturelle on nous répond
toujours sur les éléments structurels de
la crise
euh les éléments structurels vous les
connaissez je les rappelle dans notre
pays mais c'est vrai dans tous les pays
développés je sais pas si vous avez vu
le Canada par exemple refuse commence à
refuser des étudiants étrangers parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de logement donc dans
tous nos pays développés aujourd'hui le
logement est un bien rare et donc cher
donc rare et cher il y a de mon point de
vue quand même trois grands sujets qu'il
faut traiter qu'il faudra traiter à un
moment d'abord quand même traiter le
sujet de la densité est-ce que comment
est-ce qu'on gère les sujets de densité
si on veut construire des logements et
et et moi je je vais vous dire je je
considère que même la zan est un sujet
mais le zan est un sujet mais mais ce
qui est un sujet c'est surtout que les
gens doivent avoir accès à des
transports en commun aujourd'hui enfin
voilà donc donc donc de toute façon la
question de la densité se pose on sait
tous vous êtes des élus vous savez très
bien qu'une partie de nos concitoyens ne
veulent pas plus de densité on leur a
pas on on ne réussit pas à leur vendre
une densité une densité quand je parle
de densité c'est pas des trucs à 40 m
hein c'est quand même 5 étage voilà et
donc ce sujet de la densité est un sujet
qui doit être traité on peut pas dire il
y a de la non artificialisation nette et
ne pas traiter le sujet de la densité si
sinon le enfin c'est c'est mathématique
hein si ça ne s'étale pas ça doit monter
un peu et de quand je dis monter un peu
c'est quand même pas extraordinaire he
ou alors ça monte beaucoup et on a des
espaces verts ce qui peut aussi être un
sujet mais je pense que c'est un sujet
de société qui doit être traité en en
tant que tel il faut faut que la société
trouve un consensus et qu'on soit
capable de l'expliquer donc ça ça quand
même ça reste on dit les maires donnent
pas de permis c'est pas à vous que je
veux je vais apprendre que les maires
donnent les P des permis quand ils
sentent pouvoir les donner s'il a tous
ses habitants contre lui alors j'ai de
vaillants combattants mais enfin quand
même à un moment c'est compliqué quand
tout le monde est contre le permis le
maire ben il se dit bon ben voilà voilà
on va faire des choses plus
consensuelles quand même même s'il y a
des mes qui se battent je dis pas du
tout mais voilà donc il y a ce sujet de
la la densité qui va se renforcer avec
le sujet du zan qui doit être traité
c'est un sujet social important il y a
un deuxème sujet qui de mon point de vue
mais c'est c'est là où on voit que le le
secteur du logement touche profond dans
l'action publique on ne règlera pas le
problème du logement si on ne règle pas
le sujet de au fond du financement des
collectivités territoriales
euh les maires quand on arrive
effectivement avec des des projets de
logement ils disent mais vous êtes bien
gentils mais il va me falloir 30 crèche
il va falloir prendre d'école donc vous
savez dans les projets de promotion on
finance une partie de l'investissement
dans ces écoles et dans ces crèches mais
après il faut quand même recruter les
personnees faire fonctionner c'est c'est
des budgets de fonctionnement très
lourds certains peuvent le faire
certains ne peuvent pas le faire et
autre fois il y avait quand même la taxe
d'habilitation quia au fond euh voilà
ils arrivent voilà machin je vais
pouvoir bon là ça n'existe plus moi je
pense que ce alors je sais pas ce qu'il
faut faire moi j'ai pas les solutions
mais je pense que quand même le lien
entre plus d'habitants et plus de
ressource doit avoir une réalité au-delà
de la DGF parce que la DGF on l'a tous
vécu hein un jour on vous dit bonjour
vous allez plus de DGF parce que plus
d'habitant puis l'année d'ensuite il y a
un problème de péréquation de je sais
pas quoi et votre DGF baisse tout le
monde l'a vécu hein donc voilà donc moi
je pense qu'il faut accepter de traiter
le sujet du financement des budgets des
collectivités qui financent ses
équipements parce que sinon on a des
maires qui nous disent écoute vernique
bah voilà moi j'ai plus les moyens je
préférer une résidence pour personnes
âgées c'est assez bête ce que je suis en
train de dire ou peut-être une résidence
étudiante éventuellement mais là des
familles des moi j'ai plus les moyens de
financer ça sur mon budget de
fonctionnement c'est une réalité donc je
pense que ce sujet doit être traité et
c'est pas un sujet simple troisème sujet
quand même on va se dire aussi les
choses il y a pour les permis d'une
certaine taille obtenir un permis c'est
devenu une course sac vraiment c'est
très très long c'est très coûteux le
temps coûte hein on a oublié le temps
n'a rien coûté maintenant le temps coûte
et honnêtement le
nombre le nombre de normes qui se succèd
les unes derrière les autres mais ça me
rappelle j'ai l'impression d'être d'être
à la télé au 20H là les normes qui se
succèdent le fait qu'on on a et nous on
n pas l'Europe à ce stade nous n'avons
pas non non mais non non non mais moi je
je vous le dis hein mais moi je vois
même l'état quelque fois avec un préfet
qui me dit faut aller puis une
mission dans le corps de l'État qui
envoie un truc en disant mais c'est pas
possible ça répond pas on dit mais
comment comment je fais là et le maire
qui est d'accord voilà bon la recours
c'est c'est encore à la fin mais même
dans l'instruction elle-même du permis
des études des études qu'on vous demande
alors que franchement il y a pas d'objet
mais malgré tout comme tout le monde se
protège un peu ben on me reprochera
peut-être de pe pas l'avoir demandé du
coup je la demande c'est c'est c'est et
ça ça joue quand même dans le coup du
permis le temps qu'on y passe le nombre
d'études voilà donc c'est quand même une
course en sac et je pense que il va
falloir alors c'est très compliqué en
réalité la simplification mais accepter
que l'État ne parle que d'une seule voix
sur tous ces sujets alors l'état à la
fin du jour si on lui demande parle
d'une seule voix mais il faut solliciter
le préfet alors le préfet est l'homme
qui finit ou la femme qui finit par ne
parler que d'une seule voix mais dans
mais dans la conduite naturelle des
affaires honnêtement l'État a plusieurs
voix il y a des collectivités aussi qui
demandent beaucoup d'études qui changent
d'avis euh il faut d'abord présenter une
commission pour être sûr d'avoir
l'autorisation déposer votre permis ça
existe une fois que cette commission
vous a donné par un PV l'autorisation de
déposer votre permis vous nêtes même pas
sûr d'obtenir votre permis enfin je je
crois que ça ça ce que ce dont je crois
on ne se rend pas compte c'est que tout
ça se termine dans le coût du projet
c'est-à-dire que si on veut aussi
réduire le coût d'un logement il va
falloir resserrer les procédures il va
falloir accepter que l'État ne parle
puis peut-être hiérarchisser les
procédures hein parce que c'est un peu
c'est pour ça que c'est intéressant
l'agriculture c'est que vous prenez
chaque étude séparément vous dites quand
même c'est pas idiot c'est un sujet il
faut le traiter c'est juste la somme qui
s'accumule de ces procédures à la fin
vous êtes là et vous-même vous vous
retrouvez dans des instructions
contradictoires donc ça me rappelle un
peu d'autres sujets dont nous avons pu
entendre parler
voilà donc ça donc je pense que tout ça
explique pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est un
c'est un produit RAR et cher et et je me
dis aussi que c'était pas c'était pas ce
que je pensais avant mais plus j'avance
que je me dis qu'il va falloir quand
même trouver un moyen de réguler le
foncier le foncier avec la non
artificialisation net devient un bien
d'une d'une nature particulière
euh c'est pas facile hein je je suis
j'aime plutôt les les règles de marché
parce que je trouve que quand même elles
équilibrent mais quand même si on ne
fait rien du tout l'histoire risque de
très mal se terminer parce que le
foncier va devenir de plus en plus cher
vous êtes un propriétaire foncier il y a
plus de POS possibilité de de s'étendre
donc moi je pense que quand même quelque
part et c'est pas facile hein parce que
comment on fait c'est quand même une
autre affaire mais je pense qu'il y a
quand même quelque chose à faire autour
du contrôle du cût du foncier donc ça
c'est un sujet structurel euh dont
souvent euh le président quand il parle
du logement ne retient que le troisème
élément simplification qui est devenu un
petit peu le mot magique quand même euh
donc la simplification c'est un sujet ça
ne va pas tout régler
voilà euh et puis nous avons un sujet
conjoncturel qui est quand même d'une
d'une folle violence l'autre jour
quelqu'un me
disait au fond tu vois bien que quand
quand les préfets prennent la main quand
l'État prend la main les Jeux Olympiques
on fait vite et bien ce qui est vrai
enfin on était sur un territoire aussi
en reconversion c'était plus facile hein
dans voilà et puis je leur ai dit oui
vous avez raison c'est vrai que c'est
allé très vite en même temps là les Jio
c'est un
merveilleux comment dirais-je
enfin ça montre à quel point les
entreprises françaises quand elles
veulent elles font des trucs
extraordinaires vous n'entendez pas
parler de retard c'est quand même
incroyable les dél é trtendu le problème
c'est que nous tout ce qu'on a vendu en
bloc on l'a vendu mais ce qu'on va au
détail aujourd'hui il y a pas d'acheteur
n nous on n pas on n pas mis en vente
mais nos concurrents et amis qui ont mis
leur logement en vente ne trouvent pas
d'acheteur ça montre que malgré tout
même la rapidité des procédures ne règle
pas le sujet conjoncturel donc on a un
gros sujet conjoncturel vous en
connaissez les métriques c'est
essentiellement une hausse très rapide
des taux
d'intérêt nos concitoyens emprunté un
peu plus de 1 ils empruntent aujourd'hui
à 4 41 j'ai envie de dire le taux qui a
légèrement baissé depuis le mois de
novembre de de 02 points mais enfin
c'est c'est insensible mais enfin ça
c'est plutôt en train de baisser c'est
ça qu'il faut retenir évidemment c'est
entre 25 et 30 % de pouvoir d'achat en
moins euh il y a eu pour pour plein de
raisons aussi un très fort
ralentissement de la production de prêt
bancaires à la fois parce que certains
ne pouvaient plus sffrir au fond cet
immobilier aussi beaucoup parce que les
banques perdaient de l'argent puisque
avec le taux d'usure en réalité le taux
le taux de prêt immobilier ne montait
pas aussi vite que le coup de leur
ressources bon là en 2 ans la production
de prêt immobilier a été divisé par de
et ça il y a pas de mystère sur le
logement neuf moi j'ai peu de personnes
je vous le dis hein qui arrive en disant
bonjour on achète l'appartement cash les
gens ont besoin de voilà c'est ils sont
en accession ils sont en investissement
ils ont besoin ils ont besoin
d'emprunter donc ça évidemment c'est un
choc très très fort et vous voyez bien
que les banques aujourd'hui disent ben
voilà il faut on s'y remet on y va il y
a plus de clients tous les Français qui
l'année dernière voulaient faire de
l'emprint immobilier arrivve des enfin
se disent bon ben voilà il y a pas moyen
donc on est donc il y a un fort
attentisme ça va avoir des traductions
très violentes sur l'immobilier neu
c'est pire que ce que je vous disais il
y a un an c'était encore plus violent
moi je me souviens au au mois de mars
j'étais allé j'étais allée au ministère
des Finances on me dit vraiment vous
exagérez les ordes de grandeurs sont pas
les bonses non non mais les ordes de
grandeurs c'était pas les bons mais pas
dans le bon sens la crise a été beaucoup
plus violente et les prêts immobiliers
se sont arrêtés beaucoup plus vite les
chiffres de la FP vont sortir dans
quelques semaines je pense que en 2 ans
on aura on était à 160000 logements
collectifs il y a 2 ans et c'était pas
un haut historique hein on est entre 80
et 90000 là cette année l'année dernière
c'est ça l'ampleur de la réduction c'est
divisé par
de et à l'époque il y a 2 ans la maison
individuelle c'était à peu près le même
monemp c'était moitié moitié la maisoniv
je sais pas où c'est mais c'est encore
moins que ça c'est un effondrement
absolu puisque de toute façon on a dit
que c'était pas
bien donc ça c'est pour l'année
2023 ça va évidemment donc pour
l'instant ce sont les promoteurs qui
reculent moi je vais être obligé de de
réduire ma force de production de
logement ce qui m'arrache le cœur parce
que c'est pas comme si je pensais qu'
avait pas besoin enfin il y a pas de
demande
voilà et puis ça va se traduire moi j'ai
toujours dit derrière il y a le bâtiment
il y a les ressources de l'État ça va se
traduire à plein sur le BTP quelque part
au mois de septembre nous on ne fait
travailler pour l'essentiel que des
petites entreprises régionales donc moi
j'ai donc vous avez vu que les taux de
comment dirais-je les taux de de enfin
de de faillite a beaucoup grandi dans le
secteur moi je commence moi-même en tant
que patron de ne City à avoir des petits
que je connais voilà qui me disent
vonique s'il te plaît fais-nous
travailler là au S2 on a plus de boulot
mais vous imaginez si nous on se retire
de 50 % si les maisons individuelles se
retirent de Paris vous imaginez le
nombre de d'emplois qui vont parce que
nous on a calculé 150000 sur BTP mais je
me suis pas occupé de ce qui se passait
sur les maisons individuelles et
l'ampleur du choc doit pas être
tellement
voilà voilà donc donc s'il y a un choc
d'une très grande violence évidemment
moi j'ai toujours considéré que la
production de logement neuf c'était
aussi une respiration de l'existant on
est on est à peu près sur 36 millions de
logements existants le logement neuf à
l'époque c'était 360000 bon là je là on
va aller on est bien gentiment aux
alentours de 200000 donc ça va être vite
réglé ça faisit 1 % de l'existant pour
moi c'était la respiration c'est ce qui
permet à certaines personnes qui veulent
sortir de logement social de sortir ça
permet à des gens qui sont dans le bail
privé de sortir et ça permet du
mouvement aujourd'hui tout est
bloqué l'accession est je vous donnerai
un peu les de grandeur mais l'accession
est en train de tomber on voit bien que
mais c'est tout ce que j'avais dit hein
c'est ce qui a terrible c'est que le
truc se déroule exactement comme je
l'avais dit c'estàd que grosso modo
aujourd'hui dans les agences
immobilières vous avez deux fois plus de
demande de location avec 20 % d'offre en
moins euh Emmanuel COS l'a dit l'année
dernière on est passé je crois c'est 2,6
millions de demandeurs de logements
sociaux plus 7 % elle me dit ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que c'est sur tout
le territoire donc l'ensemble du système
est en train de se bloquer je pense que
c'est vraiment le moment de de faire
quelque chose
voilà pour vous dire un petit peu sur le
logement neuf donc les 100 les sur les
165000 qu'on produisait il y a 2 ans et
qui vont bientôt se terminer alors je
sais pas où au Tentour de 200 000
euh je pense que en fait il y avait il y
avait un bloc C cette production elle
avait trois grands types d'acheteurs un
tout petit tiers plutôt 25 % c'était les
bailleurs sociaux alors entre euh moi je
là pour le coup vous avez eu Action
Logement tout moi je tire un grand
chapeau je vous le dis ici à tous les
acteur du logement social j'étais à
l'USH au mois de septembre
euh voilà ils sont à la attaque autant
que leur leur leur moyens leur
permettent ils sont pas dans une
situation égale et honnêtement la taxe
foncière leur fait pas de bien comme
prélèvement de cash sur les organismes
de logements sociaux on est quand même
bien dans des proportions importantes
ils sont vraiment à l'attaque vous avez
vu enfin ils étaient Nadia et Bruno
était là ils ont fait un travail
remarquable l'année dernière la case des
dépôt est monté à l'attaque donc
vraiment moi je je tiens à saluer ici au
fond cet effet là pour le coup éric
lambard a tenté de monter en en
contre la conjoncture donc ils ont fait
leur boulot c'est pas suffisant et on
n'a pas vocation à vendre toute notre
production malgré tout euh aux
opérateurs du logement social qui
eux-mêmes vont avoir des problèmes de
financement on avait un un second euh
gros tiers c'était à peu près 38 % sur
les 5 dernières années qui étaiit euh
des des logements neufs euh destinés
pour des ventes à des particuliers
investisseurs alors ça ça s'est effondré
et ça alors là et alors l'effondrement
est précipité on y reviendra dans une
minute parce que je voudrais vous vous
montrer quelles sont les métriques au
fond
euh et en fait c'est simplement mais ça
je vous le montrerai dans 2 minutes
c'est des questions de rentabilité en
fait la rentabilité la hausse des taux
d'intérêt et et l'augmentation de la
fiscalité on vous montrera ça dans une
minute a au fond fait tomber la
rentibilité du logement qui n'est pas
comme certains l'explique un
investissement productif donc la fait
vraiment tomber et les investisseurs
particuliers qui sont plein de bon sens
bah quelque foois ils préfèrent aller
sur livra ils sont à 3 % ils ont pas de
risque c'est liquide ou alors d'autres
offres des obligations qui sont plus
rentable ou quelquefois des
actions on nous a dit que les
investisseurs institutionnels allaient
prendre le relais je crois que c'est
comme ça que le ministre a dit voilà je
pense que c'est pas très bien vous savez
le Pinel tout ça c'est pas bien
l'investisseur particulier c'est pas
bien ça n'entretient pas tac tac tac
parfait les institutionnels vont revenir
moi je vous le dis tout de suite je n'ai
pas vu l'ombre d'un institutionnel à
l'horizon et je vais vous montrer
pourquoi quoi simplement parce que le
taux de rendement attendu est bien plus
élevé que ce que que ce que peut leur
donner le le logement donc moi je veux
bien que les investisseurs
institutionnels privés reviennent les
les assurances t ceux qui ont des fonds
mais il va falloir leur donner du
rendement moi je sais pas comment on
fait et puis et puis vous voyez bien que
c'est ce sujet sur le débat qu'on peut
avoir nous en tant que professionnel
avec le gouvernement c'est quand même
bien ça qui est un peu le cœur du sujet
puisque
euh au fond le président a dit à un
moment que c'était un paradis fiscal je
pense que les Français ne s'en sont pas
aperçus en tout cas ils sont un petit
peu rétisents à aller dans ce paradis
fiscal et du coup comme comme il y a
rien à faire et ben on fait rien mais
sauf que ça ça s'effondre et ça
s'effondre encore plus en en janvier le
problème c'est que ces investisseurs
quel qu'ils soient moi je n'ai pas de
religion savoir s'ils doivent être
particulier institutionnel mais c'est
eux qui alimentent euh le le bassin
enfin du du bail privé de la location
privée qu'elle est en train de se
réduire par ailleurs grâce à à la loi
clima et
résilience on peut pas tout faire hein
on peut pas décourager l'investisseur
particulier qui achète un logement pour
créer de la loocation et en même temps
aller vaillamment sur une loi clima
rigant ce qui fait qu' il y a quand même
des là moi je vois à Cha fois je regarde
tous les mois la part des biens qui sont
en passoir thermique à la vente augmente
et aussi leur décotte he d'ailleurs je
vous le dis tout de suite parce que les
acheteurs sont un peu méfiants quand
même donc ça ça c'est ce qui a vraiment
le c'est plus le plus
effondré on avait un dernier gros tier
sur les résidences principales lui il se
repliit un peu moins c'était 30 %
c'était pas 50 % alors j'ai eu tout à
l'heure Pascal Boulanger qui m'a dit que
sur les investissements ça s'était
replié encore plus fort on va voir les
chiffres que l'on aura bon je pense que
sur l'investisseur en RP il me semble
que l'État a bougé pour le coup euh
alors évidemment c'est pas égalitaire
sur le territoire parce que vous savez
que le
PTZ donc ça moi je sais pas moi je suis
enfin suis toujours un peu méfiante he
sur ces sujetsl là je comprends la
métrique mais je dis que ça ça signifie
aussi vous me connaissez qu'on dit quand
même à beaucoup de gens qu'ils ont droit
à rien et c'est plutôt en zone des
tendue que ça se passe bref restons en
zone tendue donc en zone tendue quand
même je pense qu'il y a eu un un un
mouvement intéressant du gouvernement
sur tout ce qui était logement
intermédiaire du coup PTZ et Pinel pour
ce qu'il en reste puisque le rosonnage
qu'on a eu c'était au mois d'octobre ou
novembre permet à plus de personne de
d'avoir accès quand même au au PTZ ils
ont aussi changé les les niveaux donc
également il y a plus de personnes qui
peuvent avoir accès au PTZ et beaucoup
de banques ont bonifié cet effet
PTZ donc moi je me dis que évidemment ça
n'est pas simple mais en tout cas et et
en tout cas ça ça n'est pas vrai en zone
détendue où vous n'avez le droit du PTZ
qu'en rénovation donc clairement on vous
dit que voilà c'est uniquement de la
rénovation ça dépend où on se trouve
hein il y a des trucs même la rénovation
c'est quand même très cher hein euh mais
en tout cas je je pense que ça dans les
zones tendues ça doit vraiment aider une
partie des ménages à reprendre le chemin
de l'accès à la propriété nous on fait
notre job vous le verrez dans quelques
semaines mais moi je vais serrer tous
les coupch cheity pour abaisser le plus
possible mais vraiment je voilà le coût
du logement ça fait si 6 mois qu'on y
est on se bat pour faire baisser le coût
du logement
euh donc c'est c'est c'est vraiment ça
qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui ce que je me dis aussi moi
pour les résidences principales c'est
que malgré tout ces deux dernières
années il y a eu aussi des augmentations
de revenus j'ai vu une étude
intéressante de la BPCE qui disait
grosso modo l'augmentation des revenus
ça va effacer à peu près la moitié de la
perte de pouvoir d'achat immobilier le
prix des logement n'ont pas augmenté les
revenus ont augmenté alors faut savoir
où les Français mettent cette
augmentation de revenu hein il y a il a
de l'inflation ailleurs par ailleurs
mais quand même il ne faut pas oublier
cet effet augmentation des revenus alors
peut-être si vous le voulez bien parce
que du coup je me suis dit que la
fiscalité de l'investissement locatif on
en avait la dernière fois on n avait pas
parlé de façon détaillée euh et je
trouve alors c'est Isabelle didoi
Isabelle qui a préparé ce donc je
préférais qu'elle soit avec moi parce
que mais peut-être tenter de remettre un
peu de rationalité dans le débat sur
cette histoire de de de fiscalité de
l'investissement locatif al je sais pas
comment est-ce qu'on le passe le c'est
c'est bah merci merci donc voilài on va
parler d'investissement locatif et je
vais vous rappeler que moi je m'exprime
comme producteur de logement neuf
puisque vous savez que je suis en train
de céder criser dans mes activités de
service
syndque et que moi je ne détiens pas
d'immobilier donc au fond c'est
l'immobilier c'est c'est l'incitation à
la production de nouveau logement euh
est-ce que que alors je vais enfoncer
quelques portes ouvertes mais on va les
enfoncer ensemble euh au fond
l'attractivité c'est c'est dur à
expliquer quelquefois mais en fait le
logement un investisseur il est assez
froid euh on pense pas qu'il va faire du
logement parce que c'est une belle chose
à faire ça doit arriver mais mais il
compare il investit et il compare le
rendement de l'investissement qu'il
ferait
en immobilier avec d'autres types de
rendement les nos concitoyens sont
devenus assez agiles sur ces sujetsl
est-ce que je mets sur du livra est-ce
que je mets sur des obligues est-ce que
et et les banques proposent ce type de
produit hein est-ce que j'essaie
l'action alors qui est un peu plus
risqué mais qui existe et puis
euh donc donc je vais vous montrer un
petit peu comment nous on voit la la
réflexion d'un investisseur quels sont
qu'est-ce qui met au fond autour de
autour de la table pour pour discuter de
cet investissement et vous verrez aussi
que ça change au cours du temps d'où
l'intérêt à mon avis de mesure en flux
parce que à un moment donné du temps
quelqu'un peut faire avec un un taux
d'intérêt très bas un très bon
investissement immobilier qui va durer
dans le temps il a pas besoin qu'il soit
bonifié en stock mais en revanche le
problème qu'on a là maintenant là tout
de suite c'est que ça n'est pas un
investissement rentable et donc comme ça
n'est pas un investissement rentable ça
décline alors peut-être le premier le
premier
slide en réalité mais ça ça va vous
rappeler des des souvenirs mais en
réalité quand un investisseur
particulier ou institutionnel on a tenté
de de l'ffondre un petit peu dans les
mêmes dans les mêmes graphiques bah
qu'est-ce qu'il regarde bah il va
d'abord regarder évidemment le le
rendement brut quel est le loyer et vous
vous souvenez qu'en immobilier le loyer
il peut être bloqué hein c'est pas ce
qui se passe pour les actions ou pour
les obligations c'est des lois de marché
il va regarder ce qu'il anticipe comme
plusvue à la revente il va d'autant plus
investir que son impression c'est qu'il
va il va pouvoir il va pouvoir gagner en
en en valeur à la fin l'effet de levier
c'est-à-dire
[Musique]
l'intérêt qu'il peut avoir à investir en
empruntant quand vous empruntez à 1 %
avec votre rendement il à 3 et demi
votreet de levier est très fort quand
vous imprunterez à 4 demi et que votre
rendement est à 3 et demi vous perdez de
l'argent il y a pas d'effet de
levier évidemment le risque il y a il y
a le livr et on peu risquer et
évidemment la fiscalité alors quand on
regarde ce qui se passait en 2021 on est
en 2021 l'immobilier c'est la courbe
grise vous voyez qu'elle est au fond pas
mal équilibrée c'està dire que euh on a
un rendement brut qui est euh très élevé
enfin très élevé en tout cas c'est c'est
le plus élevé à l'époque vous voyez les
obligations orang étaient très basses
hein c'était des des des des des taux
très très bien euh il y avait une
anticipation de plusvalue à la revente
qui était pas euh monstrueuse parce
qu'on était on est déjà en 2021 euh mais
qui est raisonnable elle existe en tout
cas fort elle fait levier quand vous
empruntez à un et que votre rendement
est à 3 et dem vous gagnez à tous les
coups évidemment l'idée que c' un peu
plus risqué quand même qu'une obligation
et puis la fiscalité était un élément
très important mais surtout grâce au
Pinel hein donc qui poussait un petit
peu la rentabilité quand on regarde ce
graphique ce qu'on voit quand même si on
compare à l'action par exemple l'action
avait à l'époque un rendement moyen un
peu plus bas évidemment vous savez bien
quand un investisseur met de l'argent en
action il espère bien que l'action va
monter c'est un de ses drivers hein euh
l'effet de était était fort aussi pour
pour ce bienlà la qualité du risque
était évidemment c'est c'est une action
c'est plus risqué on le voit mais mais
les mais le prélèvement euh j'ai oublié
le le nom du de l'impôt comment service
prlèvement libératoire le le prélèvement
libératoire fait que c'est extrêmement
intéressant c'était déjà extrêmement
intéressant à l'époque donc vous voyez
que le le gris rend au fond ça dépend
comment vous êtes mais ça rend quand
même même on peut considérer
l'investissement immobilier voyez ce que
je veux dire ça a des caractéristiques
différentes mais ça se considère ça
dépend votre appétence pour le risque
voilà maintenant on est en
2024 et regardez comment les courses se
de se déforme alors qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui arrive on a toujours un
rendement on imagine un rendement
toujours à peu près de même nature les
prix de de l'immobilier n'ont pas
augmenté mais honnêtement les les
comment dirais-je les les les loyers pas
tant que ça évidemment plus aucun de nos
acheteurs estime maintenant qu'ils vont
faire de plusvalue à la revente à tort
ou à raison parce que c'est on est à 10
ans là bon il y a plus d'effet de levier
ça c'est fini puisque l'endettement
coûte plus cher que le rendement la
qualité du risque n'a pas changé et la
fiscalité s'est écrasée pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle s'écrase pas d'abord parce qu'il
y a quand même le sujet de la taxe
foncière qui rend quand même moi moi je
connais vous connaissez vous un impôt
fond un un impôt local sur les
dividendes ou sur les obligations enfin
ça n'existe pas et c'est un impôt alors
tout le monde me dit non mais c'est un
impôt qu' vocation accroîre ENF c'est
c'est mécanique c'est c'est c'est la
seule marge de manœuvre des
collectivités locales comment
voulez-vous que ça le fasse donc voilà
voilà où on en est
euh alors nous on dit voilà donc
j'entends oui on a dépensé beaucoup
d'argent oui on a dépensé beaucoup
d'argent mais on prélève beaucoup sur le
logement quand vous êtes un particulier
vous vous prenez l'IER ce qui est assez
classique vous prenez quand même une
taxe foncière qui dans certains cas
augmente très rapidement quand même faut
se dire les choses et pour pe vous ayez
un peu d'immobilier vous vous retrouvez
aveci ça ne boucle pas enfin donc je
comprends qu'on est en paradis fiscal et
que et que et que le pinal a beaucoupé
mais quand vous êtes dans un enfin voilà
moi je je sais pas mieux dire que
ça c'est on parle pas du même moment et
je pense que ce qui est intéressant de
montrer aussi là-dessus sur
l'investissement immobilier c'est que
quand même il y a des millisimes voyez
ce que je dire je pense que certains
disent non mais moi j'ai fait un
investissement il y a 10 ans c c'est 4 %
peut-être mais c'était il y a 10 ans
toutes les conditions étaient différente
et peut-être qu'il a vendu avec une
plusvalue mais là dans le moment
euh c'est c'est comme ça qu'on peut
figurer géographiquement ou visuellement
moi j'aime bien les dessins euh comment
est-ce que
euh ça ça se passe c'est un c'est un
drame hein moi je pense que ça c'est un
drame parce que ça ça ne fonctionne plus
et et vous voyez bien que monous c'est
d'autant plus un drame que lorsque on
décide de vendre au détail un immeuble
nous on avait de façon absolument
quasiment égal des investisseurs
particuliers qui arrivaient et des
résidences principales ça permettait de
vendre dans des délais raisonnables
maintenant un immeuble il ne se vend
qu'à des RP enfin voilà qu'à des
résidences principales ça peut durer des
années euh donc c'est ça ça je pense que
c'est un graphique qui montre bien
comment dans le
temps au fond la
l'attractivité de
ces de ces investissements s'est déformé
et c'est c'est de ça vous disiez tout à
l'heure comment est-ce qu'on convain moi
c'est c'est de ça c'est pour ça que avec
Isabelle on fait des graphiques vous
allez voir ce qu'on a fait on n'arrive
pas à convaincre nos autorités que c'est
comme ça que le le sujet est ici
honnêtement je pense qu'il y a plein de
choses qui vont conjoncturellement qui
vont qui vont s'améliorer il y aura pour
les RP un peu baisse de taux nous on va
faire des efforts les banques s'y
mettent l'État a fait ce qu'il fallait
sur sur le ptadansone danse je pense que
des choses vont se passer mais là c'est
un effondrement continu et et personne
et et et je pense que dans l'esprit
d'une partie du gouvernement on est
encore dans les années 2021 voilà
voilà alors peut-être donc ça on vous
laisse c'est parce que on a fait des
choix Isabelle pourra les expprimer
c'est vraiment toutes nos toutes nos
hypothèses mais peut-être plus
intéressant on a parce que moi j'aime je
pense que de plus en plus il faut dire
comment ça se passe sur le
territoire donc isabelle a fait un gros
boulot
euh alors on a on a choisi trois types
d'investisseurs donc les particuliers
qu'on avait historiquement les
institutionnels qu'on nous a promis en
disant ils vont arriver ils vont arriver
et les familles Office qui quand même
étaient très présents sur les sujets du
logement et qui se sont retirés avec l'
fi pour l'essentiel et donc isabelle a
fait le travail de comparer
l'investissement qui enfin le rendement
qui était attendu par les investisseurs
quel que soit leur catégorie donc c'est
la petite bulle rouge et la rentabilité
constatée aujourd'hui dans toutes ces
villes alors ce qui est intéressant mais
ça c'est un petit peu pour la petite
histoire mais nous on aime bien regarder
ces sujets là c'est que vous voyez bien
que la la question elle se pose en
ampleur partout le rendement n'est pas
au niveau attendu sauf àord
mais vous voyez bien que sur le
territoire il y a toujours un écart et
cet écart il est souvent plus grand pour
les institutionnels dont dont on nous a
dit qu'ils étaient un peu
l'avenir l'avenir au fond de
l'investissement que pour les
particuliers mais tant que ce sujet là
n'est pas
réglé ben on a un écart et on n'ura pas
d'investissement dans
l'immobilier ce qui est intéressant par
ailleurs c'est que ça montre moi j'aime
bien aussi ces choses qui sont très on
n' pas fait Nice on aurait pu
euh mais c'est des choses on a fait
d'unkererc parce que le ministre me
disait que lui il avait un rendement à 4
et demi mais je lui dis OUI tu as un
rendement à 4 et demi il y a 10 ans
quand tu as investi mais aujourd'hui
c'est c'est pas le cas oui non mais
c'est intéressant hein
euh donc voilà donc moi je je vous
laisse he on peut faire d'autres villes
on et si vous regardez la page
d'ensuite alors et on on on a tout voulu
regarder he l'écart en non en non parce
qu'il y a ce sujet Airbnb comment ça
marche et cetera c'est assez simple hein
bon le nom meublé c'est ce que vous ce
qu'on a travaillé jusqu'à présent qui la
colonne de de gauche et le tourisme
meublé c'est du Airbnb non classé si
vous êtes classé si vous acceptez de
classer votre investe votre avantage
fiscal est encore plus élevé mais vous
voyez que c'est marrant c'est le seul on
on a fait Paris et Lyon mais
pardonnez-moi on pourrait faire d'autres
c'est quand même le seul investissement
où le rendement que vous obtenez est
supérieur à à rendement attendu c'est
pas mal ça et Isabelle me rappeléit en
voiture elle me disait c'est d'autant
plus intéressant que on a calé nos
simulations sur c'est pas c'est pas
toute l'année c'est combien tu as pris
non on a pris un taux d'occupation de 7
mois sur 12 pour être
raisonnable c'està dire qu'on est
vraiment sur un particulier qui loue son
bien en Airbnb mais c'est pas un
professionnel hein parce que après il y
a il y a toute la catégorie des
professionnels mais là c'est juste le
particulier euh et quand même c'est
c'est c'est c'est là où c'est flagrant
il ne loue pas toute l'année mais comme
il a un meilleur rendement puisque ça
vous rapporte plus même en loyer il y a
pas de contrôle de loyer sur les Airbnb
vous êtes libre de faire ce que vous
avez à faire voilà il y a peu de risque
il vous payer avant et voilà donc le
risque est très faible et puis vous le
savez la fiscalité est bizarre
incitative donc voilà c'est ça qui se
passe donc on me dit voilà Airbnb ben
oui comment vous dire c'est c'est c'est
le seul qui soit rentable vous ne prenez
pas de risque ça c'est la rentabilité
pure vous ne prenez quasiment pas de
risque puisque vous êtes payé avant
honnêtement Airbnb a un très bon
assureur parce que quand même si vous
avez le moindre problème les trucs sont
remboursés l'assurance l'air très
performante et et c'est plus rentable
donc c'est tout ça est très normal et ce
que me rappel Isabelle c'est que si
c'est classé on prend combien de
rentabilité en plus alors si c'est un
enfin aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire fin 2023
puisque on voit que quand même la loi
est en train d'évoluer mais si en fait
on faisait classer en meublé touristique
on était à 71 % de de d'abattement au
lieu des 50 % là on a pris 50 % parce
qu'on a considéré que c'était pour une
histoire de comparabilité mais en fait
si vous poussez le raisonnement et que
vous faites classer votre noblé alors
vous avez d'autres contraintes bien sûr
mais vous arrivez jusqu'à un abattement
de 71 % c'est c'est quand même flagrant
hein c'est quand mêmeme flagrant hein ça
c'est en train de changer donc voilà
l'airbnb c'est juste ça c'est juste que
c'est très rationnel au fond c'est des
choix de nos concitoyens très rationnels
beaucoup moins de risque une meilleure
une rentabilité qui est même supérieure
à la rentabilité attendue franchement
comment vous
dire alors on me dit non mais c'est pas
grave on va on va aligner la fiscalité
du tourisme meublé sur le non meublé
mais là vous n'aurez plus de location du
tout comme ça on sera tranquille qu
enfin moi je pense que c'est pas
forcément que no concitoyens ont envie
de louer en Airbnb ils ont c'est juste
que c'est plus rentable moins risqué
donc voilà c'est la mess dite assez vite
hein bon voilà moi ce que j'avais envie
de vous montrer ce soir que dont on
avait moins discuté la la fois dernière
euh parce que je trouve que ça et on est
dispo si vous si vous souhaitez qu'on
retravaille parce que les amis je je
connais la qualité des administrateurs
du siénat et ça serait non mais nous on
est toujours d'accord pour moi ce qui me
frustre vraiment c'est que personne ne
challenge jamais ce que je dis vous
voyez ce que je veux dire Isabelle et
moi on est voilà enfin dites-nous qu'on
att tort quoi je serai ravi non non mais
vous voyez ce que je dire moi je dis des
choses je monte voyez ce qu'on c'est un
boulot remarquable qu'a fait Isabelle
pendant les vacances de Noël parce que
je je voulais avoir ça en main pour
moi-même bien comprendre ce qui se
passait mais jamais personne ne nous dit
votre est pas juste vous prenez pas les
choses de la bonne façon mais moi
j'adorerais vous voyez ce que je veux
dire parce que du coup il y a un
dialogue qui s'engage je dis je replie
je m'en va il se passe jamais rien donc
voilà à votre disposition pour partager
les hypothèses partager les calculs sur
chacune des villes on a fait des études
de marché pour vous donner les maîtrises
moyens he pour justifier en fait toutes
les positions et les calculs qu'on en a
fait et les hypothèse y compris de
personn c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on a
construit en fait cet investisseur
particulier avec des hypothèses donc on
est à votre disposition pour pour vous
les partager et pour vous donner tous
nos calculs toutes nos
hypothèses voilà un petit peu ce que
j'avais envie de vous dire aujourd'hui
parce que je pense que c'est la la
question qui est la moins bien comprise
sur lequelle il y a de plus de fantasmes
et au fond quelques calculs qui sont pas
simples hein mais mais montre enfin je
crois qu'on comprend en fait
c'est et et on est dispo pour faire avec
vous d'autres villes si vous avez envie
de regarder d'autres villes enfin mais
enfin on voit quand même ça va pas dans
le bon sens voilà VO c'est et je pense
qu'on en a fait assez pour montrer que
c'est quand même assez généralement on
voit une deuxième chose c'est que quand
même attirer des investisseurs si on
choisissait la voie de la fiscalité
attirer des investisseurs
institutionnels en imaginant qu'ils
veulent y aller hein parce que vous
savez qu'ils ont des plafonds
d'investissement en immobilier hein
chacun d'entre eux euh et ben ça coûte
plus cher d'aller chercher des des
institutionnels privés que d'aller
chercher des investisseur particulier
l'écart de rendement est plus élevé
voilà donc voilà ce que on souhaitait
vous partager avec vous ce soir après je
suis vraiment dispo pour répondre à
toutes vos questions sur Nexity sur
surtout ce que vous
voulez merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Amel tu veux peut-être poser
une question puisque si tu es contrainte
un peu par le temps merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup pour
vos apports et votre approche très
concrète euh trois trois question je
vais essayer de de poser de façon courte
vous m'avez interpellé sur
sur la la nécessaire pardon baisse du
coûp du logement à engager vous êtes en
pleine réflexion là-dessus et je pense
que tous les professionnels savent
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un impératif vous
avez évoqué la nécessité de réguler bien
sûr le cûp du foncé je pense que
pareillement même si cela peut nous
faire peur on sait que ça va être
nécessaire j'aimerais vous entendre sur
vous l'état de vos réflexions là-dessus
euh nous parlons beaucoup de et vous
l'avez dit il me semble de parcours
résidentiel grippé et bien sûr l'offre
Locat
privé joue un rôle là-dessus et
j'aimerais évoquer en fait l'impact de
la réglementation sur la lutte contre
les passeoir énergétiqu que vous avez
évoqué assez brièvement je vais vous
poser la question de toute façon un peu
malicieuse hein mais voilà demain vous
êtes ministre du Logement que
faites-vous ça fait sourire donc ça a
marché et puis puis moi je voudrais vous
remercier aussi en fait sur sur le choix
que vous avez fait de faire un zoom sur
l'investissement locatif parce que je
pense que plus concret on peut pas faire
donc bravo en tout cas pour pour cette
présentation ce qu'on nous oppose
souvent c'est le coût de ces incitations
des incitations pardon fiscales et puis
finalement le nombre de logements que
cela produit ou que ça nous permet de
mettre sur le marché j'aimerais vous
entendre aussi là-dessus hein vous avez
en partie bien sûr répondu mais mais ce
qu'on nous oppose souvent c'est ça c'est
quand on voit ce que ça coûte et
finalement ce qu'on met sur le marché
bien sûr on faitfit complètement vous
l'avez pas dit mais vous avez raison un
investisseur il il raisonne de façon
très froide voilà
rentabilité mais je le dis souvent parce
que moi je suis vraiment fortement
attaché et je suis attaché à la promesse
aussi voilà républicaine il y a aussi
l'autre attachement qui est de dire
voilà c'est la façon de se constituer un
patrimoine c'est une donc ça aussi c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant je pense
qu'il faut mettre dans la balance
particulièrement dans le contexte que
nous sommes en train de traverser dans
ce pays c'est des retraites hein ça par
de retraite hein de retraite et de
transmission c'est ça patrimoine donc
transmission et bien sûr la retraite qui
est aussi pour moi un élément fort à
mettre dans la balance là on ne parle
pas que de chiffres mais vous avez
raison c'est c'est aussi un élément fort
donc voilà je je vais m'arrêter là
j'aurais peut-être d'autres questions
mais mais là merci beaucoup encore une
fois je vou souhaitez que je réponde
tout de su peut-être par rapport à au
cout de construction qui inexorablement
amène une baisse des surfaces à
destination donc ça aussi c'est on a vu
pour les surfaces n'ont cessé de baisser
par rapport à des prix aujourd'hui qui
sont plus importants mais on a moins de
mètres carrés et donc avec ce que ça
peut
en se poser comme problème en
particulier sur les logements familiaux
euh peut-être commencer par cette
question puis après dérouler les autres
je j'attire votre attention cependant
sur le fait que aujourd'hui euh on on on
a fait beaucoup moins de petits à la
demande des mères beaucoup hein de
petits logements sauf que c'est sur ces
petit logement aujourd'hui qui a
beaucoup de euh de tension tout
simplement parce que la décohabitation
la l'augmentation de la durée de vie les
étudiants les étudiants qu'est-ce qui
leur arrive il y en a pas tant de ça de
plus c'est qu'autrefois il trouvaient
dans le secteur privé à louer des T1 ou
des T2 en 1 et aujourd'hui ils arrivent
en compétition avec des jeunes euh qui
commencent dans la vie Activ ou des gens
qui décohabitent qui ont des salaires
ils n'entrent pas en compétition c'est
pour ça aussi y a donc moi je pense
qu'il faut aussi refaire un petit peu de
de petits de petits logements parce que
là on en a fait beaucoup de grands mais
il en manque un peu de petits aussi et
c'est là-dessus que que sont les
tensions aujourd'hui la demande elle
porte plutôt sur ses petits
logements sur la nécessaire baisse du
coup du logement nous chezity on est
plutôt des guerriers donc on on dit ce
qu'on a à dire mais en fait on se bat
moi je pense que malgré tout et quoi
qu'il arrive il faut qu'on fasse baisser
le coup du
logement alors il y a des solutions qui
qui passent qui ne passe pas forcément
par la baisse des mètres carrés de log
de toute façon avec toutes les
réglementations qu'on a désormais je
pense que ce serait extrêmement
compliqué parce que dans le Pinel on
nous dit même de combien les M les
balcons doivent mesurer tout ça donc je
pense que notre marge de manœuvre
là-dessus est quand même assez faible
euh dans un produit classique France
entière chez nous le coût du foncier
c'est à peu près 23
%.
euh moi je ne vois pas beaucoup baisser
le prix du foncier il y a moins il y a
moins de compétition délirante enfin je
ne vois pas baisser
euh et je pense que alors tout le monde
me dit que ça va baisser moi je sais pas
si dans le contexte du zan un bien qui
devient de plus en plus rare son prix
baisse non non mais l'économie peut nous
faire des grandes surprises hein mais je
sens pas cette histoire d'où d' d'où ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure moi je
pense que les mécanismes de marché ont
quand même les signau au prix ont quand
même souvent beaucoup d'intérêt mais je
pense qu'il va quand même falloir qu'on
fasse attention euh et et honnêtement au
CNR j'étais plutôt une voix dissidente
sou le CNR dit il faut trouver des
moyens euh de c'était vraiment le une
sorte de consensus du groupe de de de au
moins de contrôler ou de surveiller les
coûts du foncier moi je me disais non il
faut que quand même le marché voilà je
je suis comme je vous l'ai dit je suis
revenu je me dis que quand même c'estain
c'est en train de de de devenir un bien
vraiment spécifique qui va devenir
vraiment très rare enfin donc je je de
nouveau je ne sais pas quoi mais je
pense qu'il y a au moins commencer à
observer commencer puis après il y a
peut-être des moyens de régulation mais
ça je je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit
très attentif après on a à peu près 50 %
du cût c'est c'est vraiment le coût de
construction la moitié de ce coût de
construction c'est des coûts humains
c'est des salar des salaires je vois pas
ça baisser après c'est des intran des
intrans je pense que ça peut baisser un
petit peu quand même parce que
l'inflation est un peu passée je pense
que certaines entreprises ont
reconstitué leur margein c'est ce que
line s'est dit donc ça je pense que ça
peut baisser un
peu on voit les prix commencer à baisser
un tout petit peu hein sur le gros œuf
mais moi je me méfie un petit peu parce
que enfin chezité on est très prudent
sur les prix que nous propose
aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'entreprises on ne veut pas qu'elles
fasse des prix très bas pour gérer leur
problème de trésorerie et faire des prix
trop bas qui fait qu'elles ne tiendront
pas le coup voyez ce que je veux dire il
y a des patrons prix à la gorge qui pe
qui peuvent accepter à un moment donné
de prendre des des marchés à des prix
trop bas pour faire bosser ses ses
équipes mais ça il faut faire faut être
très très vigilant parce que un une
boîte qui qui au fond tombe en faillite
au milieu d'un chantier d'abord c'est
pas une belle histoire et pour nous
c'est terrible donc on est extrêmement
méfiant mais enfin quand même je pense
que les coups de construction vont au
moins se calmer après je pense que c'est
aussi à nous en tant qu'entrepreneur à
faire le boulot comment comment est-ce
que moi je réduis mes coups de F je suis
vraiment complètement là-dessus hein
comment je réduis mes coups de
fonctionnement comment je réduis mes
coups de marketing comment je suis plus
efficace et on regarde aussi la
construction modulaire avec une boîte
auquel on s'est intéressé qui est une
boîte qui vient de la tech qui nous
permettrait
d'avoir des appartements qui seraient re
2020 2030 à des coûts inférieurs alors
c'est 3 4 % hein de nouveau aucun
mouvement ne crée un truc voilà enfin 3
4 % moi je les prends aujourd'hui hein
et c'est vraiment des choses qui sont
vraiment très très belles nous on les a
présenté à quelques mè parce que qui
était un peu rétiscant donc on a fait
une expo à Paris on leur a montré c'est
c'est vraiment superbe vous ne je vous
défie de de me dire de l'extérieur
queussi de la construction modulaire
vraiment vous je je pense que vous ne le
ferez pas euh et la la qualité de de
construction est une qualité
industrielle donc ça peut être utile
dans certains cas euh ça peut pas
répondre à toutes les questions mais en
tout cas voilà donc nous en tout cas à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise aujourd'hui
et je pense que on annoncera un certain
nombre de de de choses fin février on
est vraiment concentré sur qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui nous
permettrait à nous de baisser le coût de
construction bon évidemment si on
réussiss à tenir à peu près les coups de
fonciers et construire un peu plus par
définition voilà après il va falloir
aussi réexaminer le sujet des parkings
des parkings coûtent très très
cher c'est c'est très enfin une place de
parking ça vous renchéit nous on s'était
dit à un moment on va tenter de vendre
nos appartements sans vendre les
parkings enfin en même temps ça ça vous
vous retrouvez avec des parkings n on se
retrouve avec des parkings en main donc
moi je je pense qu'on simplifie va quand
même regarder falloir regarder le plus
souple sur le sujet des parkings euh sur
le parcours résidentiel grippé moi ce
que je je pense qu'il faut une politique
globale du logement vous ne pouvez pas
aujourd'hui à la fois
dire on est on lutte contre les
passeports énergétiques et et vous me
connaissez assez pour savoir que je
pense qu'il faut le faire d'accord je
enfin je suis vraiment une militante de
ces sujets là moi je suis convaincue que
le temps nous est compté bon enfin quand
même la loi a été voté sans qu'onit une
idée tout à fait précise de de quoi on
parle exactement moi je me souviens de
la sortie il a 2 ans en île-de-fance des
des travaux de de l'Institut urbain là
qui est vraiment de très grande qualité
et qui dit ben voilà en fait euh les
passeoirs thermiques dans les 10 années
qui viennent c'est 50 % du parc ah non
mais c'est pas du tout la même histoire
là donc ça je pense que on ne peut pas
dire ça euh tenir ça ne rien faire sur
lescopropriétés on nous a annoncé une
loi que personne ne voit venir je vous
le dis tout de suite alors il y a des
trucs simples à faire quand même il y a
quand même des trucs simples à faire
sans toucher au droit de propriété sans
tout le monde s'évanouisse en séance
enfin il va quand même falloir qu'on
fasse quelque chose quoi et puis en même
temps dire qu'il y a pas besoin
d'investissement en logement ça ne
boucle pas ça ne boucle pas et je pense
que le problème de la politique du
logement aujourd'hui c'est c'est c'est
vraiment ces tranches de saucisson je
prends une tranche de saucisson les
passepirs thermiques c'est pas bien
aucun d'entre nous ne peut dire
l'inverse il faut vraiment et c'est
souvent ne pas comprendre la
sociologie de de de ce qu'il y a
derrière vous avez des des grands
propriétaires fonciers je pense qu'ils
ont tout à fait les moyens de faire mais
tous ceux des classes moyennes qui ont
fait un un petit C ou un petit ce sont
souvent des femmes pardonnez-moi
mesdames mais c'est vrai qui arrivent
dans nos agences elles ont 70 ans on
leur dit bonjour donc elle elle pensait
qu'elle s'était faite une retraite enfin
avec leur mari pensait que s'était faite
une retraite complémentaire on dit ben
écoutez pas de chance vous êtes en vous
êtes une passeir thermique vous ne
pouvez plus louer enfin vous imaginez
enfin c'est c'est c'est c'est une
retraite complément nous hein et puis on
leur dit bah si vous voulez reprendre
faut faire des travaux enfin et voilà ça
va vous coûter à la fin alors je sais
pas en combien en trésorerie mais la fin
ça je dis n'importe quoi mais c'est
leure de grandeur moyen 40000 € mais ça
n'existe même pas en rêve enfin même pas
en rêve et puis vous choquez quand même
des gens hein qui qui étaient pas dans
et qui étaient pas des propriétaires
malhonnêtes et cetera et ils ont ils
découvrent leur enfin voyez voyez ce que
je veux dire donc moi je pense que tout
tout ça ça milite il faut il faut des
ordres de grandeur
si on fait ça ben il faut une vraie loi
qui permet d'accélérer parce que moi moi
je dis c'est c'est il faut faut être un
militant faut être un syndique militant
pour faire la rénovation thmique nous on
le fait on s'est battu on avance enfin
c'est vous passez 3 ans à vous battre
contre les moulins sans rien gagner sans
gagner d'argent faut quand même être
très militant
hein et sur l'investissement locatif le
coût du Pinel oui certes mais comment
vous dire moi j'ai envie de dire
faites-nous une flat taxe comme vous le
faites sur les dividendes et je ne
demanderai plus rien je demande pas de
Pinel je demande plus rien le Pinel ça a
l'avantage de gérer les trucs en flux
quand même hein vous voyez ce que je
dire parce que euh si vous faites en
stock ça peut et que vous égalisez tous
ces ça peut ça peut quand même coûter
très cher à la fin du jour donc oui le
Pinel ça coûte cher mais que voulez-vous
que je vous dise moi j'y peux rien l'IER
plus la taxe foncière plus l' fi euh
l'État l'toit perçoit 90 milliards sur
le logement et il verse 38 milliards
donc je veux bien que il y a jamais
moyen de mettre ces deux chiffres face à
face donc euh donc voilà ce que je
question que je les réponse que je
pouvais apporter à vos
questions Viviane est-ce que tu as une
question quelques réflexion et question
aussi sur moi je suis d'accord avec vous
qu'il faut on peut plus passer d'avoir
une vision systémique on peut plus
travailler en silo d'un côté le logement
social je crois que plutôt que de parter
de parcours résidentiel il faut penser
de par cours de vie quel quels besoins
ont les gens à tel moment de de leur vie
voilà de leur vie quand on est jeune on
n' pas les mêmes besoins jeune étudiant
on n' pas le même besoin que quand on
est que quand on est ou quand on est
retraité je rejoins avec vous audà de
l'investissement de le logement qui est
un investissement privé pour certaines
personnes raison on le voit pour
d'autres c'est un un comment dire une
assurance pour leur retraite voilà et
puis parce qu'on sait aussi pas
forcément pour le louer pour un
complément de retraite mais quand on
sait que lors de la retraite quand on
voit le coût du logement dans le niveau
de vie ce que on ne paye pas en loyer on
l'a en niveau de vie quand on a une
petite retraite donc voilà il y a ça
aussi et puis la question vous l'avez
dit aussi du transmission d'un
patrimoine on est tous moi je je je vois
je suis devenue propriétaire en héritant
de de mes parents voilà et et je j'étais
dans une génération bon cette idée de
d'être propriétaire c'était pas
forcément trop voilà mais maintenant je
suis bien contente d'avoir d'avoir ça et
je suis bien contente de pouvoir le
transmettre à ma fille et ainsi de suite
voilà euh moi j'avais bon puisqu'on a
parlé beaucoup des questions de
fiscalité aussi je suis d'accord que
effectivement l'immobilier n'est plus un
rendement suffisant on voit beaucoup de
personnes qui se qui se désengagent je
crois que l'impôt sur la fortune
immobilière aussi fait que bah
effectivement on a d'autres actifs qui
sont plus rentables et que ça a été
c'est pas c'est pas des bons signes
voilà d'avoir supprimé l'impôt sur la
sur le capital et d'avoir gardé celui
sur la l'immobilier étrange voilà c'est
étrange voilà je suis d'accord avec vous
euh voilà sur la question de de le moi
c'est la question de vous avez parler
aussi du fait des des problèmes
structurels la crise du logement elle
est là depuis un moment elle elle est là
et effectivement elle s'est aggravée
dernièrement avec ce que vous avez vu
sur l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt
mais aussi la l'inflation et cette
conjoncture qui est là mais par contre
on a quelques discours de la part du du
Trésor notamment qui semble dire que la
crise elle est surtout là maintenant à
cause de de ces de ces problèmes de
d'inflation de d'augmentation des des
taux d'intérêt et que la que en fait que
la crise n'est que conjoncturelle un
petit peu il n'y a on semble on reentend
encore ce problème du que la crise n'est
pas besoin pas besoin de logement voilà
en ouverture du CNR non qui cette
présentation
trés dis et puis cette question par
rapport à la fiscalité aussi ce que vous
dis il faut c'est ver qui l'a dit il
faut sevrer le logement de la fis de la
drogue fiscale voilà il a dit texto
voilà donc on est bien là vers un un
gouvernement qui est un petit peu qui
n'écoute enfin qui est comment dire que
sour à toutes ces à tout ce qui est que
qu'on le répète depuis un moment que
c'est une crise structurelle pour vous
donc comment vous vous avez vécu en fait
ce cette ce conseil national de de la
refondation logement bon je sais que on
avait l'impression que vous aviez été
très très frustré quand même de ce qui
était sorti et là du coup est-ce que
vous vous pensez
que comment dire que
que ce que vous avez proposé euh dans
dans
le dans dans le CNR les proposition
elles sont toujours d'actualité mais
est-ce qu'il faut pas proposer d'autres
choses compte tenu que la crise
s'aggrave avec ce qui est cette
conjoncture qui qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas bonne en plus et puis la deuxème
voulez les impacts aussi de cette crise
bon vous en avez parlé sur le les
questions de d'emploi dans la filière du
bâtiment sur la production et cetera on
a les mêmes chiffres et que nous donne
cette filière là sur les pertes d'emploi
et les entreprises mais vous sur Next
City et les promoteurs en particulier
cette baisse d'activité est-ce que ça
peut entraîner aussi des difficultés
chez des petits promoteurs de de vie et
et et dans
quelle comment dire dans quelle
temporalité aussi j'allais dire et puis
en terme de perte d'emploi aussi dans
dans ce secteur là et qui qui qui moi à
mon avis c'est c'est inquiétant parce
que je pense que si on ne réagit pas
rapidement on mettra des années voire
des dizaines d'années à se remettre de
de cela je peut-être commencer si quand
même ce que nous disaient les
intervenants de la Table Ronde
précédente c'est de prendre en compte
quand même l'in
merci du marché du logement c'estàdire
que même s'il y a des mesures qui sont
appelées de nos vux assez rapidement
souhaitonsle pour autant voilà cette
inercie fait que déjà l'année 2024 on le
sait elle sera compliquée et
difficile peut-être peut-être commencer
par la fin sur les
promoteurs les promoteurs ils sont
aujourd'hui dans un marché qui s'ffond
de la moitié en 2
ans c'est ça notre ité à peu près enfin
on va voir les on va voir les chiffres
que sortent la FPI mais on était à
165000 logements il y a 2 ans et là on
va être aux alentours de 80 85000 oui je
sais pas enfin je connais pas encore les
chiffres enfin voilà
donc donc je pense qu'effectivement et
là je crois que les chiffres sont là il
y a évidemment beaucoup de petits
promoteurs qui mettent tacté sous la
porte parce que ils ne vendent plus en
fait ils vendent plus voà et je pense
que les gros promoteurs comme nous euh
bon on a on a tenu on a tenu 23 en se
disant qu'il fallait
tenir parce que il y a un vrai besoin de
logement enfin moi c'est ça qui me comme
patron de boîte c'est ça qui me déchire
au fond c'est que je sais qu'il y a
besoin de logement moi ce que je vais
être obligé de faire mais comme tous
autour de moi c'est détruire une partie
de l'appareil de production Vinc a déjà
annoncer c'est hard l'a fait pendant ses
vux même constat il a dit ben voilà il y
a pas de moyen je je lancer un PSE chez
moi la décision n'est pas prise
simplement parce qu'on est en train de
regarder comment on s'organise et
cetera mais c'est clairement une
hypothèse qui est sur la table je peux
pas vous donner les ordres de grandeur
mais ils sont conséquents une entreprise
qui intervient de façon sur un un un
comment dirais-je sur un temps assez
long et la crise elle est là depuis 18
mois sur un marché qui se réduit de 50 %
et rien ne bouge elle est vraiment
obligée de se vous avez vu hein j'ai
déjà vendu mes activités de service de
syndique sur lequel nous étions très
impliqués pour me désendetter parce que
quand quand quand vous vendez moins au
particulier ben il y a moins de recette
qui rentrent c'est pas voilà et donc on
va être obligé tous de prendre donc le
moment des promoteurs c'est maintenant
voilà c'est je pense qu'on vraiment on a
tenu on s'est dit c'est pas possible il
va se passer quelque chose et cetera il
ne se passe rien donc voilà on va le
faire maintenant et derrière nous il y
aura le BTP et le BTP c'est 6 mois après
à mon
avis ça ça va être assez massif hein
c'est c'est normal le marché c'est un
marché qui se réduit de 50 % vous en
connaissez beaucoup vous des marchés qui
se réduisent de 50 %. moi
j'ai je comprends pas comment il y a pas
une
réaction et c'est un peu comme sur le
nucléaire he moi je je fais cette
comparaison c'est-à-dire que enfin nous
on va faire ce qu'on a à faire on ne
peut pas porter des on peut pas on ne
peut pas avoir des outils de production
gréer pour un marché deux fois plus
grand on peut tenir un peu on l'a fait
parce qu'on je pense qu'on était tous
convaincu qu'il avait quelque chose à
faire maintenant on va être obligé d'en
tirer les conséquences mais on détruit
un outil de production que je vous
promets qu'on aura vraiment du mal à à
parce qu'on va perdre des jeunes qui
vont aller sur d'autres métiers le
métier de la promotion n'est pas un
métier facile hein obtenir un permis en
ce moment c'est quand même un grand
momentin il faut faut être un guerrier
faut pas décourager parce que sinon vous
n'y arrivez jamais ça vous l'obtenez
jamais du premier coup donc voilà donc
non non je moi je l'ai dit hein je je
pense que ça va être assez massif on l'a
dit on le dit depuis octobre 2022 quand
même hein euh moi j'avais dit en octobre
2022 que vu les enfin c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est faire juste un peu
d'économie et tr règles de TR c'est je
pense ça va être plus lourd que ce que
je prévoyais à l'époque plus massif et
ça va durer enfin je le la baisse des
taux on sait pas quand est-ce qu'elle
intervient elle va pas régler ce
problème là pas enfin c'est pas on va on
va perdre un point de taux et je sais
pas combien de temps combien de temps ça
va se refléter vraiment dans les dans
les taux d'intérêt dans les trait
intérêt immobilier euh quand quand on
dit qu'on a un énorme problème sur
l'investissement particulier on nous
répond mais ké il faut vous sevrez de je
sais pas quoi enfin c'est terrible hein
je je vous avoue que dans le secteur
entendre ça quelquefois c'est c'est
juste enfin voilà c'est la réalité elle
est là je peux pas la montrer mieux que
ça euh effectivement on a de l'aide
fiscale mais on on est on est sur
surfiscalisé que je vous dise moi moi
j'attends avec impatience que les
dividendes que se prennent une t
une taxe une taxe comment
dirais-je une taxe locale et qu'on
remette l'ISF ça ça va aller beaucoup
mieux pour l'immobilier non mais là là
vraiment donc honnêtement entendre ça
c'est c'est plus qu'agaçant ça fâche ça
fâche parce que la réalité elle est
celle-elosition
sera sur plutôt sur la fiscalité que
vous feriez les nouvelles propositions
par
rapporti moi de nouveau il a des
proposition il y en a partout sur la
table c'est un concours l'pine de
proposition ça sert à rien de faire des
propositions si on n pas d'accord sur le
diagnostic moi je tout le monde des
propositions j'ai C tous les jour dis
qu'on a une bonne idée honnêtement si le
gouvernement pense qu'on est aujourd'hui
dans l'investissement sur un paradis
fiscal c'est pas la peine de faire le
concours
l'pine enfin honnêtement moi je moi j'ai
là pour le C j'ai confiance dans nos
administrations si on leur dit le
diagnostic c'est vraiment ça il rien
rien à dire on a besoin de plus de
logement je sais pas combien puis que
voilà bon le le problème va se régler
assez simplement on a de très belles
administrations qui savent faire ce
qu'il faut euh mais pour l'instant ça
sert à rien enfin le CNR il y avait
plein de propositions partout tout le
monde en fait partout moi je dis que
faisons enfin vraiment le diagnostic est
important est-ce que oui ou non on a
besoin de logement est-ce que oui ou non
on a besoin d'alimenter le secteur du
paill privé et après on après on déroule
hein je pense que qu'est-ce qui vous a
empêché au CNR de faire ce diagnostic
mais nous mais nous on l'a fait on l'a
fait tout ça c'était là mais simplement
on n' pas eu on n jamais eu ce qui est
très étonnant c'est je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est c'est de ne pas
être capable d'enclencher une vraie
décision une vraie une vraie vous voyez
ce que je dire honnêtement moi je me
souviens je suis allée je suis allé
partout on avait passé des dimanches à
faire des fiches pour montrer les sujets
enfin et moi j'espérais simplement qu'un
jour quelqu'un me dise tes fiches sont
fausses ce que tu dis est on m'a dit non
mais on ne partage pas le même
diagnostique mais d'accord très bien
mais dis-moi et on peut pédaler dans la
smoule très longtemps hein dire que vous
y allez enfin tu on l'a fait enfin tu tu
es témoins enfin moi j'ai produit un
nombre de fiches on voyez ce qu'on
essaie de
faire c'est pas clair donc moi moi je
suis sûr que je fais la même chose dans
certains ministère demain matin il ne se
passe rien personne me rappelle en
disant mais ton calcul est pas juste
alors c'est moi je suis enfin vous voyez
ce que je veux dire donc et et donc on
n'arrive pas euh j'ai entendu Bruno
Lemer l'autre jour qui me dit c'est très
cher ce serait mieux si je les faisais
moi-même ou et cetera je sais plus ce
qu'il a dit au quotidien comment vous
dire moi je ne sais pas enfin je je sais
pas quoi faire là je tout est là en fait
tout est là h mais ça ne ça on ne est-ce
que c'est parce qu'on considère
véritablement que ce n'est pas une
priorité moi je pense que plus largement
ouais moi je pense que si vous voulez
fond de ma pensée moi je pense que ce
qui me frapp beaucoup de
l'extérieur et vous allez voir des
analogies à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
je pense que la parole au fond des
entrepreneurs du monde du privé n'est
pas du tout prise en compte nous sommes
des lobbyistes c'est ça vous voyez ce
que je veux dire et donc les lobbyistes
c'est pas bien oui on est des lobbyistes
mais on dit aussi des choses je je pense
que ce qui se passe en ce moment je
j'imagine très très bien je je le vois
je le vis moi fait a d dire quand même
voyez voyez ce qui se passe les ha vous
pensez que les ha il fallait que les
tracteurs montent sur Paris pour régler
les problèm des ha en vrai non mais non
mais j'y crois pas moi donc moi je pense
qu'il y a de ça il y a
aujourd'hui une c'està-dire que cette
parole vraiment quand c'est quand c'est
obligé il nous écoute il nous reçoivent
très poliment il y a 17 personnes on est
vraiment écouté mais il y a jamais
personne qui a rebondit sur ce qu'on a
dit et moi je n'attends moi mon mon
bonheur absolu serait quelqu'un me dise
ton raisonnement est complètement faux
tu sais pas tu sais pas compter la
fiscalité c'est pas ça mais moi je
serais ravi Isabelle serait ravi aussi
mais non ça ne se passe jamais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire donc c'est ça
on n'arrive
pas pourtant vous voyez bien je me suis
exprimé et mais il ne se passe mais
alors ça fait 18 mois il ne se passe en
réalité jamais rien parce que regardez
hier quand on lit la double page dans la
Tribune le crche immobilier enfin je
veux dire les médias aujourd'hui quand
quand même relais les les les et voilà
même ça ça ça ne ça ne change rien ça ne
ne
n'interpelle personne enin personne au
niau ver bien ce que dira Gabriel à tal
demain mais mais le ça va être noyé dans
un ensemble de le le problème aussi
c'est que quand même donc il y a un
problème structurel qui est là une
politique de l'offre qu'on nous a
annoncé brillamment que que dont je n'ai
jamais vu le début du commencement d'une
réalisation et donc je pense que une
partie du gouvernement est resté bloqué
sur cette politique de qui ne bouge pas
par ailleurs les simplifications vont
tout régler partout maintenant ça j'ai
bien compris euh mais n'entre pas dans
la crise conjoncturelle avec l'idée
peut-être que la crise conjoncturelle va
au fond régler un cble de sujets des
actcteurs qui vont disparaître une
nouvelle économie va naître j'attends
avec impatience la tête de la nouvelle
économie dans les conditions euh
fiscales et financières qui sont les
nres aujourd'hui non c'est c'est pour
moi avec mon histoire euh c'est c'est
vraiment étrange h
euh je je
et vraiment on a tenté de démontrer ça
on a tenté de de mais mais je sais pas
j'ai l'impression d'être dans un monde
parallèle et de de ne jamais vous voyez
ce que je veux dire euh faire un bout
d'encoche quelque part c'est fait c'est
trè qui est fou c'est que quand même
aujourd'hui ce qui était pas forcément
le cas par le passé tous les acteurs
vous parlez quand même tous de la même
voix même si sur certains points vous
n'êtes pas tous d'accord mais nous on a
fait une table ronde au niveau de la
commission des affaires économiques
depuis christophe Robert que vous
connaissez forcément très bien euh
jusque bien sûr aux promoteurs à la
Fédération du bâtiment à l'ushh aux
agents immobiliers enfin je veux dire on
a quand même une unanimité de voix qui
qui qui sont porté en disant et malgré
tout je veux dire là il y a eu
l'Alliance pour le logement donc tout le
monde se démène tout le monde essaie de
voilà nous les politiques autant que
faire ce peu en tout cas ici au niveau
du du Sénat ça fait quand même un moment
aussi qu'on qu'on alerte sur tous ces
sujets je je pense que les mots de
Gérard larch ont pé quand même
oui il faut jamais sous-estimer le poids
de la représentation nationale elle est
forte je pense que le fait que Gérard
l'arché parle du logement oui oui c'est
ça même pour nous ça a été un moment on
s'est dit tiens enfin quand même le
terrain bouge et le président du Sénat
je pense que quand même ça a eu un vrai
impact jamais sousestimer le poids du
Parlement jamais Sousou même s'il est un
peu mal mené pour autant mais vous avez
raison il faut encore garder et c'est
vrai que voilà quand dès le mois
d'octobre après le Renou nouvellement du
Sénat il m'a dit bon il faut que la
commission des affaires économiques se
saisisse de ce sujet voilà c'est pour ça
qu'on veut aller assez vite mais bon en
même temps en ayant quand même la
possibilité de d'entendre le plus de de
de d'acteurs poss possible pour
peut-être à travers alors je sais que
l'Assemblée nationale réfléchit aussi il
y a des il y a pas mal de travaux qui
partent un peu sur plusieurs sujets mais
l'assemblée elle est beaucoup he
oui l'Assemblée pour ce que j'envois moi
il y a la il y a la la mission qui a été
confiée sur le rendement locatif oui ça
tu en vois d'autres
oui c'est c'est plus des sur sur des
thématiques à chaque fois c'est pour ça
que nous il nous a dit vraimenton crise
du logement et essayant de de de voilà
d'être force de proposition donc on va
tout faire pour et en s'appuyant bien
sûr sur vos témoignages mais moi je je
pense vraiment que s'il y a une voix du
Sénat sur le diagnostic
euh la réalité simplement oui déjà c'est
beaucoup hein que que et puis porter
quand même de façon transpartisane hein
ça c'est important aussi parce que on
peut avoir quelques divergence sur
certains points y compris avec viian
mais quand même globalement on l'
constaté partout le logement est quand
même assez consensuel en tout cas en
tout cas je pense ou alors on est arrivé
dans des systèmes où les sujets ne sont
traités que lorsqu'ils sont en crise
aigu ce qui peut être aussi un non mais
ça peut être aussi un sujet hein là je
vous rassure on lesurs les tracteurs
sont pas encore sortis mais enf au mois
de septembre entre les Français et le
BTP on sera vraiment arrivé très loin
euh mais oui c'est je je pense qu'il y a
cette frustration qui est pas de mot il
y a jamais de mot sur ce qui se passe en
réalité du président il a dit qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit là pend son il a dit oui il
y a une crise du logement les promoteurs
sont sous tension honnêtement il y
aurait que nous sous tension ce ne
serait rien je vous le dis les Français
sont aussi un peu sous tension et le BTP
est est aussi oui euh donc ça fait un ça
commence à faire un mélange un peu plus
dangereux donc oui enfin je pense que
comme beaucoup de secteurs dans dans ce
pays on a envie aussi que il y ait des
mots sur ce qu'on est en train de vivre
il a des mots aussi pour les Français
moi moi c'est ce que ce que je ce que je
je disais ce matin enfin dans ou ce que
j'ai voulu faire ressortir dans
l'entretien de la tribune on est en
train de bloquer toute la France qui
bouge
euh les gens moi moi c'est pas grave je
peux attendre je suis là où je suis
depuis 20 ans je vais il y a pas
d'urgence mais en revanche tous les
jeunes
qui veulent faire des études les jeunes
qui veulent euh qui veulent bouger pour
trouver un boulot qui veulent faire des
stages euh les tous ceux qui veulent
avoir des enfants c'est moi j'attendais
quand le président a dit on a un
problème démographique honnêtement
j'attendais un peu bêtement le sujet du
logement je suis un peu tombé de ma
chaise donc le problème c'est un sujet
hein moi je me suiens quand on était
jeune enfin savoir si on avait les
moyens d'avoir une pièce en plus c'était
quand même un vrai sujet enfin tout ça
n'existe pas euh t ceux qui décohabitent
tous ceux qui veulent bouger pour
trouver du boulot et ben tout ça tous
ceuxl ils sont dans des difficultés
alors sauf s'ils ont beaucoup d'argent
là dans ce cas-là tout va bien mais la
plupart des Français qui veulent bouger
sont en d'un difficulté très importante
ils ne peuvent pas bouger il y a plus de
il y a plus de logements sociaux
disponible les les beau privés sont en
train de diminuer
euh enfin voilà enfin ça ne va pas enfin
ça ne va pas du tout on peut pas dire
que la France va bouger si on empêche
tous ceux qui sont sont en capacité de
bouger de bouger sur le territoire ça
n'existe
pas voilà vous l'avez compris ma
conviction sur ce sujet est toujours
aussi fort on nen doutait pas écoutez
merci
beaucoup et puis bien évidemment si on a
besoin on reviendra vers vers vous et en
tout cas merci de nous avoir consacré ce
temps extrêmement précieux dans votre
emploi du temps et dans vos nombreuses
obligations et responsabilité nous
comptons sur vous oui on va essayer de
on va essayer d'être à la hauteur d'
certain nombre de d'attentes ou en tout
cas d'apporter des des réponses merci
beaucoup bonne soirée à vous au
plaisir